vorab kurz die frage geklärt duzen sie
beide sich oder sieht sie sich ja und
das bleibt auch so über den wahltag
hinaus wird während des wahlkampfes auch
danach genau und hat man während dieses
wahlkampfs dann wirklich eng wird viel
kontakt miteinander oder meidet man den
er es kommt darauf an finden es gibt ja
manchmal gelegenheiten wo es gar nicht
mit parteipolitik zu tun hat sondern
operative dinge zu klären sind das war
am anfang des wahlkampfes so und
zwischendurch ist es schon so dass wir
uns das eine oder andere zu rufen wenn
wir glauben das ist jetzt aber nicht in
ordnung sind sie befreundet kann man so
weit gehen ich finde den begriff
freundschaft in der politik wahnsinnig
schwierig und vermeidet den see also ich
benutze ihn sehr sehr wenig ich würde
sagen paul das für einen engen draht
haben dass wir gelernt haben in der zeit
in der wir zusammenarbeiten dass wir uns
aufeinander verlassen können gerade
mache mir ein bisschen sorgen um ihn
aber es ist ein vertrauensverhältnis da
und es wird auch durch den schwierigen
wahlkampf nicht nicht belastet wenn das
so kommt also gerade mache mir ein
bisschen sorgen bisher schon die erste
show ja das ist ja das ist ja normal das
hat er sicher vorher aufgeschrieben und
muss das jetzt hier mal platzieren jetzt
hat herrn punkt gefunden und jetzt schon
mal da kommen jetzt gleich noch während
der sendung ein paar andere sprüche aber
die habe ich ja sie haben sich doch auch
den jahr ausschreiben
ich hoffe er macht also dass darüber
überhaupt pathetisch sprechen nein aber
ich finde das muss man auch noch mal
sagen dass in einer demokratie es
durchaus ja völlig normal ist zu sagen
wir haben ganz unterschiedliche
positionen wir konkurrieren miteinander
und trotzdem kann man menschlich ein
sehr gutes verhältnis haben und das
wichtigste ist glaube ich fast dass wenn
man was bespricht dass man sich auch
darauf verlassen kann dass das eben
vertraulich behandelt wird und das
können wir ist es einfacher jemanden zu
bekämpfen richtig anzugehen wenn man ihn
nicht leiden kann persönlich nicht
leiden kann ich glaube man muss
unterscheiden zwischen den personen das
ist sicherlich so wenn man jemand
weniger markt dann fällt es einem
leichter aber es geht um die parteien
und um die inhalte und da fällt es mir
überhaupt nicht schwer die spd zu
attackieren weil ich die inhalte für
falsch halte das heißt auch jemanden
lars klingbeil den sie persönlich ja
offensichtlich mögen sonst tut benutzt
man sich ja nicht mehr
dabei steht ja für die politik der spd
und ich finde sowie lars klingbeil mich
kritisiert für politische inhalte
kritisiere ich ihn für politische
inhalte und die wählerinnen und wähler
müssten sich dann ein bild machen was
für uns in was für ein land sie
zukünftig leben und wie geht das mal das
ja das netz ist einziger mit den sorgen
gerade also wenn ich jetzt kennt paul
jetzt schon länger setzen uns aber wenn
ich jetzt lebe das jetzt auf einmal so
mit antieuropäischen ressentiments
gearbeitet wird dann dann weiß ich das
ist nicht er weiß dass er das in der
rolle gerade macht und trotzdem finde
ich schade dass er jetzt einen solchen
weg gehen muss aber das erklärt sich
natürlich ein bisschen auch aus der
momentanen lage in der die union drin
ist dass man jetzt von seiten der union
in panik modus verfällt und taufen muss
vielleicht nur zur erklärung wenn was
lars klingbeil leinwand ist ja die spd
will die schuldenunion in der
europäischen union sie will eine
sozialunion das alles kann man muss das
ja mal sagen was meine ich damit um das
auch zu erklären dass heißt deutliche
lieblings verachtet schon jetzt heute
aber man muss das ja mal kurz dahinter
steuerzahler sparer sollen haften für
die schulden anderer staaten ein
sozialsystem in europa das wird es mit
uns nicht geben weil wir das geld auch
deutscher steuerzahler bürgerschützen
und das leben wir zutiefst ab also jeder
deutsche kann sich darauf verlassen dass
die union aufpasst dass wir keine
schuldenunion bekommst meinten dass ein
tag mit ihr ist und ich lehne es ab
übrigens wird auch ein zusammenhalt in
europa es wird den zusammenhalt in
europa schwächen oder gar die eu sehr
beschädigen weil es dafür keine
gesellschaftlichen mehrheiten gibt das
wir haften für die schulden anderer
staaten das will die spd das linie ab
will der kurz darauf gegen hellas musste
weil das ist wirklich das was mich
schockt weil ich paul kenne weil ich
weiß dass überzeugt europäer es aber ein
satz den er gesagt hat dass jetzt die
deutschen steuerzahler für die
rumänischen rentner geld bezahlen sollen
das ist ein antieuropäische
ressentiments was da gefüttert wird dann
macht man ganz klar wahlkampf gegen
europa und ich finde es wahnsinnig
unwürdig wir haben in dieser legislatur
merkel scholz haben den europäischen
wiederaufbau gehen auf den weg gebracht
700 sagt sie am rand und da stellt
jemand wie paul signac ja die eigene
geschichte auch die eigenen erfolge
dieser legislatur und frage ich weiß das
von friedrich merz dass auch andauernd
aber dass der general
da will ich mal ganz leer ins jahr
gestellt die mit scholz mit makro mit
lena die die einen wahnsinnig wichtigen
europäischen weg gegangen das ist das wo
ich wo ich wirklich tief ist mitleid
empfinde wenn man auf einmal anfängt mit
diesen antieuropäischen ressentiments
sei es ist das gegend es ist das
gegenteil also erstmal zum recovery for
es war eine jahrhundert pandemie eine
jahrhundertkatastrophe
ein einmaliger ein einmaliger akt
europäischer solidarität aber das kann
keine dauereinrichtung werden dass wir
aber ist sean penn beschwerden union
schlittern und deswegen sage ich jetzt
mal ganz deutlich weil ich europa liebe
will ich dass europa zusammen bleibt und
wir wissen dass es dafür keine
mehrheiten gibt in deutschland keine
gesellschaftlichen mehrheiten ihr wollte
seite wir haben dafür sie hat es im fall
einer gesellschaftlichen mehrheiten für
eine schuldenunion und wir wollen
natürlich nicht weil es das wird europa
schwächen dass wir sozialleistungen in
anderen staaten finanzieren das ist der
absolut falsche weg und ich sage auch
als gebürtiger pole ich will nicht dass
europa kaputt geht weil es dafür keine
unterstützung gibt deswegen brauchen wir
einhaltung von stabilitätskriterien und
nicht eine schuldenunion so wie es die
spd sich das vorstellt ich weiß nicht
woher das jetzt gefunden hat mit der
schulden union ich finde schade dass man
einen erfolgreichen weg der letzten vier
jahre in frage stellt ich glaube das was
die deutsch französische achse ausmacht
dass man jetzt auch in europa und
innovation setzt dass man sagt wir
treiben digitalisierung klimaschutz
gemeinsam voran wir nehmen dafür geld
jedes land haftet ja für die eigenen
gelder das ist auch ganz wichtig zu
sagen dass im bundestag so beschlossen
worden dass europa eigene steuern
aufnehmen könnte und nochmal das macht
mich ein bisschen traurig dass eine
stolze partei wie die union jetzt meint
wenn wir gegen die anderen länder
agieren wenn wir diese billigen
klischees bedient dann können wir uns
noch mal punkten in der schlussphase des
wahlkampfs das ist traurig ich weiß dass
das der rolle geschuldet ist und ich
hoffe ich dass sie doch weil viele nicht
mehr absagen es ist doch nicht gegen die
anderen länder sondern es ist
miteinander oder mit den dallas stars
mit stabilen dagegen mit folien in
rumänien hetzt dann ist die hölle die
anderen ende sagt war nur als auch
andere wahl das geht nicht da hat sich
eine sozialunion geben soll das heißt
doch gemacht
meisterschaft kämpfen die
vergemeinschaftung von diesen leistungen
das ist doch das ziel einen 1 das ziel
dass wir eben eine kasse haben in die
dann natürlich länder wie zum beispiel
die bundesrepublik besonders einzahlen
das lehne ich ab und noch mal mit uns
wird es das nicht geben weder eine
solche soziale union bei dieser
kollision dieser satz mit uns wird es
das nicht geben
der löst bei mir ehrlich gesagt so eine
gewisse heiterkeit aus wald das gibt es
längst in eine gemeinsame europäische
kasse es gibt einen etat es gibt länder
den mehr bezahlt wird den weniger
bezahlt wird es war die deutsche
kanzlerin die immer eine sehr andere
position hatte speziell unter einem
finanzminister wolfgang schäuble und die
dafür europaweit ich habe nämlich noch
eine situation gefeiert wurde im übrigen
auch von ihrer eigenen partei dass sie
genau diese haltung in oder vor dem
eindruck dieser partie aufgegeben hat
das heißt das wollen sie wieder
rückabwickeln oder was heißt dann seien
das war einmalig und zwar befristet auf
grund der korona pandemie in diesem
moment weiß nicht ich deswegen habe ich
auch selbst dafür bestimmt aber das kann
doch kein dauerhafter zustand sein sonst
schlittern wir hinein und wir werden
dadurch nicht mehr stabilität in europa
bekommt sondern weniger stabilität wir
sehen ja wir haben ja gesehen in der
vergangenheit in vielen ländern übrigens
auch in griechenland als nicht die
aktuelle regierung sondern
sozialistische regierung dort
bewirtschaftet haben wozu es geführt hat
diese mehr mehr schulden bringen am ende
stabilität und wohlstand funktioniert
nicht wir sehen wir sind gut durch diese
letzten jahre gekommen übrigens auch
durch die korona krise weil wir ein
bundesfinanzminister wolfgang schäuble
der gespart hat wir haben die gesetzlich
glaube wer schulden sondern sie sich
ohnehin ausgeblieben sind oder was holz
und 9 ausgeglichen und den täglichen den
haushalt ja deswegen waren wir jetzt
tabellenletzte ja ein letzter führst du
gerne auch noch mal verstehen und
nahmen das schon ja genau die
sozialunion und das ist ja auch richtig
dass wir in europa gemeinsame
sozialpolitik machen dass wir sagen es
muss überall ein mindestlohn geben dass
wir sagen überall muss es auch schutz
von arm investoren überall gleich nein
oder gleich den korridor wir sagen es
muss über lohndumping in europa muss
bekämpft werden dass wir sagen es muss
überall soziale sicherungssysteme geben
dass wir sagen es muss aufgabe sein
überall in europa kinderarmut zu
bekämpfen jugend arbeitslosigkeit zu
bekämpfen das macht doch europa aus dass
wir für einander auch solidarisch sind
aber der eindruck der hier weg der
eindruck der event wird ist deutschland
bezahlt für den rest und das ist ein
bisschen wie gar nicht
tragen weil das möglichste baut schulden
union das ist dass wir eine sache und
sie dürfen eine sache völlig negiert der
haut sie mir wenn wir in europa nicht
stärker werden gemeinsam dann verlieren
wir den wettbewerb gegen china gegen die
usa gegen anderen deswegen muss europa
stärker zusammenhalten armin laschet
fährt über zu makro nach dem urlaub
schon zwei tage vor dabei muss armin
laschet ja auch und einen tag später
haut der generalsekretär der cdu ein
antieuropäische ressentiments einen tag
später kommt friedrich merz und beerdigt
sagen das wahlprogramm der union was
europa politik angeht wenn er sagt wir
wollen die vier millionen nicht wir
sehen was im programm der cdu das ist
das ist das ist doch tragisch für eine
partei ich hab ja nie helmut kohl
unterstützt aber ich meine der waren
große europäer und jetzt kommen die und
machen hier komplett rasur sind sagt
david der verfassung würden sie sagen
paul margis am anti europäer dann er
muss gerade den anti europäer geben weil
es darum geht das jetzt doch noch ein
paar wähler mobilisiert werden und das
ist natürlich sagt inger vorwurf sind
sie ist einfach so und das ist absurd
und ich glaube ich brauche das weder zu
beweisen noch zu kommentieren es ist
einfach absurd aber wir sehen doch in
diesen wesentlichen fragen dass wir doch
nur ein starkes europa behalten wenn wir
auch die meinung in den einzelnen
nationalen staaten berücksichtigt können
wieder statt in der in derber
entschuldigung wir bei müssten sie ihre
politik in der außenpolitik in der
verteidigungspolitik dort wo ihr
gesperrt gegen gemeinsame standards zum
beispiel beim export von rüstungsgütern
anderen dingen mehr da müssen wir stark
sein wir müssen stark sein zum beispiel
in der frage transatlantische
handelsabkommen spd hat janka ist seit
der senioren krach geschafft überhaupt
zuzustimmen bei dem freihandelsabkommen
mit kanada
große teile der spd haben gegend tipp
das freihandelsabkommen mit den usa
geweckt hat das verwirklichen dass
dieses europa geschwächt wird weil wir
gemeinsam das was wir vereinbart haben
stabilitätskriterien für den
wirtschaftsraum aufgeben und schulden
schulden schulden machen und deutschland
und andere staaten haften und dafür habe
ich viel unterstützung übrigens nicht
nur in deutschland sondern auch in
anderen staaten geht es um deutschland
zunächst mal in richtung europa
wenn es um europa geht geht es auch
immer um deutschland und wenn es um
deutschland geht geht es auch immer
swing ist diese wahl haben sie ja so
interessant ist ja jeder drauf schaut
doch natürlich schaut er alle schauen
worauf man keiner die bänder erst wenn
europa nicht stark germany verein
natürlich nicht warum gewinnt das haben
sie doch gerade gesagt nein das habe ich
nicht gesagt herr lanz jetzt ganz
heimlich waren wir genau sagen wir
driften gerade in eine ecke ab sobald
jemand sich bekennt mal zu wichtigen
kriterien der stabilität wird er sofort
und das beste ist ja nicht das kann das
wäre als ob man antieuropäisch ist weil
man darauf dringt dass die verträge die
wir alle miteinander unterschrieben
haben eingehalten werden und deswegen
wir brauchen ein starkes europa ich bin
überzeugter europäer ein fan aber ich
sage auch wir müssen doch mal die kirche
im dorf lassen wir haben verträge an die
halten wir uns dazu gehört auch okay
dass wir nicht für die schulden anderer
staaten auf die kirche im dorf lassen
die wohl im land halten so könnte es
laufen nicht wahr also ich also kein da
und das ist ganz klar
das böse wort schulden union ist wohl
das ist ja so dass ist ja auch so dass
sehr interessant wir werden auch gleich
über so ein paar ganz entscheidende
triggerpunkte und für diesen wahlkampf
sprechen weil hier heute sozusagen die
die spin-doktoren wie man auf neudeutsch
sagt sitzen da fallen immer wieder so
trigger momente fallen einem allen die
wir noch immer wieder weitererzählt
werden negative erzählungen drum
entwickelt usw wenn dinge weggelassen
die dem anderen helfen könnten und so
weiter
schulden union ist es das was sie vorher
nein als spd nah steht sagen sie einmal
kurz was sie vorhaben wir finden dass
das was jetzt in dieser legislatur auf
den weg gebracht wurde dass in europa
eine gemeinsame
investitionspolitik stattfindet mit dem
wiederaufbau von dass es da auch
möglichkeiten geben muss das zu
verstetigen das haben wir gemeinsam
übrigens stetigen wir haben gemeinsam im
parlament übrigens heißt dauerhaft so
richten gemeinsam haben wir im parlament
beschlossen dass europa zum beispiel
auch alleine steuern erheben können so
ja das haben wir gemeinsam beschlossen
das wollen jetzt nicht mehr wissen aber
sozusagen sozusagen europa muss als
wirtschaftsraum stärker wir werden
gemeinsam muss in digitalisierung in
klimaschutz auch geld stecken können
damit wir noch mal im wettkampf mit dem
ja mit china dass wir stark werden ich
glaube dass europa wirklich die
wichtigste deutsche aufgabe ist aber das
ist ja sozusagen eines gemeinsamen etats
wenn sie sagen man muss selber auch
schnell wenn er meine damit es ja gerade
schon da in einem haushalt nicht am eu
haushalt und was jetzt aber das
charakteristische meint was jetzt
verabredet es ist ja dass jedes land
haftet auch für die eigenen beiträgen es
geht ja nicht darum dass man die
verantwortung für deutsche steuerzahler
haften nicht für die schulden der
anderen das ist ja der vorwurf
das ist ja das was wir gerade machen und
ich glaube diesen weg muss man doch
jetzt geschehen macht gehen und das
worum es uns doch gerade erst mal geht
es zu sagen haben wir eine gemeinsame
zielsetzung dass wir sagen europa muss
stärkeren integration schritt noch gehen
das was wir gerade in dieser legislatur
gemacht haben das kann man dauerhaft zu
machen sie sind gerade völlig auf einer
linie märkten sind eigentlich deswegen
finde ich sehr sicher tragen als ich
rede jetzt hier selbst jungen leuten
über einen schein konflikt auf einen
mangel an dass das ihn einst das worum
es doch geht es gerade mit dem versuch
wagt der schulden union das eigene lager
zu mobilisieren das ist das was gerade
zu sagen die sozis wollen euer geld
ausgeben deswegen alle jetzt mal gegen
die idee und das funktioniert über den
umweg einer gegnergruppe sind das finde
ich tragisch bei der partei die cdu
versiert und ich bin schon sagen kann
heute noch eine schule und eine
fachliche frage wird mich wirklich noch
interessieren weil sie sagt europa muss
in der lage sein eigene steuern zu
erheben und das ganz kurz abzuräumen wer
an welche steuern denken sie da das
heißt zum beispiel die frage also auch
das ist ja etwas was wir in dieser
legislatur versucht haben schon zu
finalisieren was noch nicht geklappt hat
aber die frage finanztransaktionssteuer
also ist das steuer dem
eu budget geht wir haben auch darüber
geredet als wir den antrag im parlament
verabschiedet haben das ist zum beispiel
die frage emissionshandel sein kann dass
das eine eigene einnahme vielleicht
jetzt nicht steuer aber neigen
einnahmequelle für europa ist und dass
dann damit natürlich auch das geld was
europa aufnimmt dass das damit getilgt
werden kann das macht ja eigentlich
sogar nur global sind
finanztransaktionssteuer macht er ja
aber sie mal als europäisch sind ja ja
ja macht mehr sein bloß sagen dass es ja
das ist ein eklatanter unterschied und
diese worte da darf man sich nicht von
beeindrucken lassen verstetigen sie
haben gerade angesprochen verstetigen
ist ja weiterhin weiter entweder immer
weiter hineinschlittern und es wird dort
finden das heißt dass ein zusätzliches
gemacht ich finde es falsch
dann lernen wir aus vier bewerber nennt
wenn wir permanent weiter gehen nicht
auf die stabilitätskriterien achten
immer weiter schulden gemacht wird und
am ende wird es dazu kommen dass
diejenigen die nur bei sehr
stabilitätsorientiert zu reis und dass
ich auch nicht und deswegen sage ich
diesen weg wird es mit uns nicht geben
und da gibt es einen eklatanten
unterschied zwischen sozialdemokraten
und uns
was wir gerade erleben ist wirklich
wahlkampf vom allerfeinsten wie sehr
ärgert sie erzählt ist jetzt wieder das
alte duell cdu gegen spd die sehr ärgern
sie sich dass sie so spät nicht sie
persönlich aber offensichtlich dass auch
noch allen our house gemerkt haben dass
es gar nicht gegen die grünen geht
sondern es ist der gegner sitzt da sie
haben sich ganz lang am falschen gegner
abgearbeitet
zur wahrheit zur wahrheit gehört
tatsächlich das aber stimmt das nicht ja
vor allen dingen monaten waren die
grünen noch der hauptmitbewerber jetzt
weiß ich dass alles besser wissen und
hein sein das waren alles abzieht
patricia bock nicht als besserwisser
sondern das haben wir nach der
nominierung bei den grünen war erstmal
ein großer halb und den haben wir alle
gesehen und dann wurden magazine mann
hatte die titelblätter überall nur noch
annalena baerbock die grünen die super
partei streben sogar einige absolute
mehrheit ist sogar möglich dann kam das
buch lebensläufe und vieles andere mehr
eigentlich nebensächlichkeiten hat ja
mit inhalten nicht viel zu tun aber dann
entwickelte sich das so schon dann
entwickelt und glaubwürdigkeit das ist
eine andere das ein handgriff frage gab
es waren keine parteipolitischen inhalte
in einer auseinandersetzung
und dann gab es auch fehler auf unserer
seite gar keine frage wir waren ja sehr
wir hatten ja eine sehr lange phase bis
wir überhaupt einen kanzlerkandidaten
hatten wir haben der parteitag war sehr
spät da wurde erstmal über den vorsitz
der cdu entschieden digitaler parteitag
der erste volldigitale parteitag
überhaupt der super war der super
gelaufen ist und dann eben sehr spät die
kanzlerkandidatur dann diskussionen auch
vor der kanzlerkandidatur innerhalb
unserer partei das gehört dazu es ist
ein prozess den wir gehen müssen aber
eben sehr spät und dann gab es ein
hochwasser im rohwasser war
logischerweise armin laschet als
ministerpräsident gefordert ich fand es
auch sehr richtig dass er gesagt hat das
ist jetzt mal eine priorität ich kümmere
mich um das hochwasser haben und nicht
jetzt um wahlkampf und so sind die dinge
gelaufen aber schauen sie sich jetzt mal
schauen sie mal nach niedersachsen da
gab es vor einigen wenigen wochen ende
august eine umfrage dieser glaube ich
die spd 12 prozent vor uns im
landestrend und jetzt haben wir das
ergebnis der kommunalwahl unterliegen
wir vor der spd sind stärkste kraft in
niedersachsen bei dieser kommunalwahl
also umfragen sind immer interessant und
natürlich als generalsekretär auch auf
die umfrage aber wir wollen die wahl
gewinnen sie wollen die wahl gewinnen
aber ich habe gerade im hintergrund
dieses dieses foto gesehen das ist ja
mittlerweile an fast schon vielleicht
kommt das noch mal kurz zeigen ein fast
schon ikonografische foto
dieses lachen
kostet ihnen dass die kanzlerschaft
also die wahl ist ja wir wollen ja die
wahl gewinnen habe ich gerade gesagt wir
haben jetzt gerade gemerkt nach diesem
wochenende nach dem trial nach dem
auftritt von armin laschet auf dem
csu-parteitag dass wir jetzt richtig
rückenwind haben für diese zwei wochen
und zudem foto armin laschet hat ja dazu
schon alles gesagt hat sich an dem tag
noch geäußert dass ja das ist ein moment
als ich das foto gesehen habe wo waren
sie wo waren sie war glaube ich bei
einem termin für unterwegs gab es auf
dem mann haben sich das wiedersehen ich
hab dann haben sie sehen ja ja direkt
als ich meine sie sind der spin doctor
sie sind derjenige ist also da kommt so
ein moment da kommt dieses foto das doch
das ist doch der gau da kommt es doch
darauf an wie ron wenn das jetzt ab ich
habe es gesehen und das gleiche gedacht
was sie gedacht dann wahrscheinlich dass
alle gedacht desaster
also ja ja ja das ist so was darf nicht
passieren und armin laschet hat es ja
auch gesagt ich verstehe also menschlich
bin ich gehöre ich nicht zu denjenigen
die sagen wenn es wenn es an so einem
tag man unterwegs ist wir waren wir
waren ja auch betroffen in meinem
wahlkreis in iserlohn in lasbeck war war
hochwasser in der stadt altena
es ist mein wahlkreis in altena sind
feuerwehrleute bei uns im märkischen
kreis gestorben beim einsatz und dann
ist man unterwegs und deswegen weiß ich
das darf immer viele viele dinge
aufeinander kommen klar und trotzdem
darf so ein moment nicht passieren weil
er natürlich den eindruck vermittelt bei
denjenigen die es sehen da gibt es eine
stimmung die gar nicht zu dem passt was
menschen gerade erlebt habe dass armin
laschet auch schon gesagt das ist ja das
tragische daran also das hat ja nichts
mit politischen inhalten zu tun nun aber
es ist der moment der alles verändert
das ist ein moment der sehr viel zu sehr
viel gesprächsstoff für gesprächsstoff
gesorgt hat berichterstattung und
natürlich haben mich menschen darauf
angesprochen
wenn man armin laschet erlebt hat in
diesen tagen und das habe ich jeden tag
ich weiß wie ihn die ganze flut und die
todesopfer mitgenommen haben umso mehr
wusste ich als ich dann die
berichterstattung darüber sah
fand ich es auch muss ich ganz ehrlich
sagen fand ich jetzt auch so unfertig
weiß wie ihnen das emotional bagdad
erklären das ist ja das ist ja auch
unfair also das dann einfach so zu
nehmen und nur noch darauf abzuheben ist
ja auch unfair wenn man alles andere
tisch fallen lässt was mich
interessieren würde ist was ist die
geschichte dahinter warum hat er in dem
moment so gelacht über anderthalb
minuten was ist da passiert ich war
nicht dabei
sie haben fast 1000 mal darüber
gesprochen und die 1000 mal nicht ich
habe an dem tag oder so wie kann das
sein und haben nachgefragt und ich kann
ihnen die geschichte nicht genau
erzählen aber es gab eine irgend eine
anekdote jemand erzählte in dieser runde
das aus diesem flutgebieten dass jemand
glaube ich dann obdach verloren hat also
sein haus verloren hat woanders
unterkommen und irgendwie war irgend
etwas nettes also war eine nette
geschichte wie bei jemandem den guten
dem geholfen werden konnte und in dem
moment was eben so dass das dieses bild
dabei entstanden ist das ging es war
eine positive geschichte wo jemand
erzählt ich glaube ich weiß ich will
jetzt nicht jemandem was unterstellen
aber auf jeden fall ist aber sie kennen
die geschichte dahinter nicht wirklich
ich kenne die geschichte nicht wirklich
will sie auch nicht weiterhin also ich
will jetzt nicht irgendwelche sachen
erzählen die ihnen an dem tag vom
hörensagen gehört habe aber was ich
sagen wollte ist ich fand dass in dem
moment war natürlich waren die reaktion
so wie sie waren
und ich wusste wie hat dieser mann also
armin laschet in diesen tagen gearbeitet
hat und auch natürlich danach und davor
und wie sehen das mitgenommen hat auch
emotional als familienvater als er das
leid der menschen gesehen hat und dann
wird das natürlich durch moment der
nicht passieren r verkürzt und das fand
ich fand das nicht als unfair in der
berichterstattung aber ich fand es nicht
ausreichend weil ich weiß wie hart er da
garantiert er klingbeil wann haben sie
dieses foto das erste mal gesehen diese
szene und wann war ihnen klar das ist
das ist möglicherweise das einfallstor
da gehen wir voll drauf
also ich habe die szene direkt an dem
nachmittag gesehen ich habe mir das 67
mal angeguckt diese kurze videosequenz
auf twitter und habe gedacht das kann
nicht sein also wenn der bundespräsident
redet dann stehst du als
ministerpräsident wahrnehmen oder du
stehst so dass du hörst was der
bundespräsident selbst weil er ja auch
unmittelbar danach geredet hat also das
muss man einfach machen das gehört sich
und so blöd das jetzt klingt aber als
ich die nächsten morgen um 8 bei mir in
münster mein müll rausgebracht habe und
mein nachbar mir zurief der nichts mit
twitter oder sonst was zu tun hat hast
du das gesehen was er da gemacht hat da
wusste ich dieses bild bleibt hängen es
gibt von wenigen politikern gibt es
wenige bilder die wirklich hängen
bleiben im kollektiven gedächtnis der
republik und das ist das bild das armin
laschet bis heute prägt also ich muss
das wirklich so beschreiben bis heute
kommen menschen bei mir an dem infostand
egal wo ich im land unterwegs bin und
sagen der darf nicht kanzler werden ist
diese szene oder so ist das schwerin
darauf zu reduzieren ich meinen also
also das was er einmal werden sie das
erzählen einmal grantig wurzeln haben an
der grafik vorbereitet vielleicht können
wir ja mal ganz kurz zu machen aber eher
lang sehr interessant ist mich zeigt die
zustimmungswerte sozusagen im laufe
dieses wahlkampfs was da eigentlich wann
passiert ist und es ist wirklich sehr
sehr interessant wie wie die einzelnen
gucken sich entwickelndes lassen jetzt
einfach mal moment auf uns wirken und
sie hat sie mir sagen das was sie gerade
sagen wollten jetzt hat gerade lars
klingbeil die geschichte erzählt dass er
von seinen nachbarn an gesprochen wurde
dass er das gesehen hat die wahrheit ist
dass lars klingbeil direkt unmittelbar
als das noch in keiner zeitung stand bei
twitter schon diesen ausschnitt wird
mein nachbar
du hast ist sofort bei twitter gesehen
in einem bundestagswahlkampf ich will
nur die geschichte damit wir jetzt nicht
ganz so gewaltig weil es so aussieht als
ob der armee lars klingbeil am nächsten
tag erst von den bürgern darauf
angesprochen wurde denn lars klingbeil
hat das potenzial in dem wahlkampf
gesehen in dieser bilder und hatte
sofort natürlich ist verbreitet wenige
wie glaube sogar wenige minuten nachdem
ist das erste mal gesendet wurde wie
viele minuten danach her klingt das weiß
ich nicht ich weiß weil das auto
genommen oder versöhnliches gesehen habe
hab ich
hab ich das dann sehr schnell verbreitet
aber ich weiß nicht ob das eine stunde
danach war dann eine halbe stunde eher
nicht aber natürlich das ist ein bild
was etwas ist ja nicht ganz an die daten
der union aus ja ist schon klar